I'm president of a company called
business laboratory and we build
computer simulations for businesses and
governments we use Mathematica in every
project that we do we build computer
simulation models and these are often
large systems designed to be replicas of
large organizations so we need the power
of something like Mathematica to do
those kinds of calculations to be
replicas of companies so that we can ask
a lot of what if strategy kinds of
questions of these models to help these
companies determine their best decisions
going forward we chose Mathematica
really because of three key things for
us speed power and flexibility
Mathematica does its calculations in a
enormously high performance way it can
work on very large very diverse data
sets including unstructured data sets
Mathematica can do just about whatever
we ask and perform any kind of function
we've used statistical functions we've
used the optimization functions we've
used a lot of the graphics primitives we
do a lot of our work in visualization
and mathematica gives us the flexibility
to put together very fine-grained
visualizations of the systems at hand
and these visualizations are critical
for allowing our complicated models to
communicate in non-mathematical ways to
our audience which are often company
executives our clients don't often know
what analysis is needed until they see
it so Mathematica ability to put
together very quickly these prototypes
of analyses that we could perform for
them allows them to see a bit of the end
games we're working on lots of different
projects right now one of the projects
that we're working on is with a chemical
company and the chemical company runs a
very complex set of processes to make
a nylon they came to us to ask us to
optimize the system optimize the
chemical supply chain for them we use
Mathematica to build that simulation
model and it enabled them to enhance
their profitability in a significant
sort of way I would say to anybody who's
doing serious work and analytics
Mathematica really is the the tool of
choice it's powerful it allows
integration with all kinds of data
sources and then you can build on that
analysis further by adding more complex
functions as necessary so it really is
the perfect environment for doing
serious work in technical computing